this animation is brought to you by the
Association of migraine disorders
migraine is not just a headache it's a
complex neurological disease that
impacts more than 1 billion people
worldwide you can learn more about
migraine at
www.m migrain disorders.
org when a migraine attack occurs rescue
medications can help ease your pain
let's look at what happens in your brain
during an attack and how different
medications can affect this
process during an attack your nervous
system becomes overly activated it
stimulates trigeminal nerve pain fibers
and blood vessels in your
meninges which are the tissues around
the outside of your
brain when the pain fibers are
stimulated they release calcitonin Gene
related peptide which is abbreviated as
cgrp as well as other chemical
Messengers
cgrp causes blood vessels to dilate
which leads to throbbing
pain cgrp also activates your immune
cells such as mast cells and gal cells
they release cyto kindes that cause
local
inflammation cgrp also sensitizes the
trigeminal nerves which play a part in
sending signals back to your brain stem
and onto the rest of your brain
resulting in more pain and other
symptoms serotonin another
neurotransmitter can perform a lot of
functions through receptors found on the
surface of different cell
types during a migraine attack serotonin
attaches to receptors 1B 1 D and 1 F on
trigeminal nerves which in turn
instructs the nerves to block the
production of
cgrp with less cgrp there is less pain
and inflammation in the
menes and the rest of the
brain serotonin also calms a migraine
headache by activating receptors 1B and
1D on blood vessels that prevent their
painful
swelling the goal of migraine
medications is to stop the migraine
attack by interrupting the chemical
processes causing
it medications called triptans can mimic
serotonin and bind to its one being and
1D receptors on trigeminal nerves and
blood vessels triptans reduce the amount
of
cgrp and constrict swollen blood vessels
resulting in reduced pain and
inflammation during a migraine
attack but because the serotonin
receptor 1B that causes blood vessel
constriction is also found throughout
the body triptans can also cause heart
strain high blood pressure and
stroke as a result trip Tans must be
used with caution in people with
significant cardiovascular
risks there are seven different trip
Tans and they vary in how quickly they
work and how long they
last how quickly they work also depends
on whether they are delivered as a pill
nasal spray or
injection new Rescue medications don't
constrict your blood vessels and don't
have the risks that trip Tans do for
example gepants are a group group of
small molecules that minimize migraine
pain by blocking cgrp from binding to
its receptors primarily on nerve
endings lasmiditan is the first of a
different group of small molecules
called dians lastin Works similarly to a
triptan except that it only activates
the serotonin 1f receptors which are
located primarily on the trigeminal
nerves not blood
vessels lastin Mak cause drowsiness so
driving should be avoided for 8 hours
after taking it Urgot medications such
as DHE activates several serotonin
receptors like
triptans Urgot last longer than triptans
but they take more time to work and are
harder to get into your
body they can be effective but like trip
Tans they cause blood vessel narrowing
which makes them risky for patients who
are older particularly those with cardio
vascular
risks progins are chemicals in your body
that can cause blood vessels to swell
within and around your
brain they can also increase
inflammation and your body's sensitivity
to
pain cyc oxygenase enzymes called Cox 1
and Cox 2 are critical in the production
of
prostaglandins non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs or ineds such as
ibuprofen and aspirin block Cox enzymes
and therefore block prandin production
and pain the ined celic coxib is less
likely to cause gastrointestinal side
effects such as nausea heartburn and
ulcers than other ineds because it only
blocks Cox 2
enzymes another rescue medication called
butalbital is a type of
barbituate butalbital is often combined
with caffeine acetaminophen or aspirin
to treat migraine but babol can be
addictive and may cause many side
effects including upset stomach vomiting
shaking dizziness drowsiness trouble
sleeping and dry
mouth taking a rescue medication as soon
as symptoms start is important for
quickly aborting a migraine attack and
reducing the risk of the disease
becoming
chronic but there is a danger with
overusing rescue
medications avoid using a acetaminophen
and ineds more than 14 days a
month and avoid using triptans babol or
Urgot more than 9 days a month frequent
use of these medications can lead to a
different type of headache called
medication overuse headache the efficacy
of rescue medications is different for
everyone finding the right ones for you
involves trial and error some
medications can be more effective when
used in combination for example trip
Tans gants and dians can be taken with
inseds adding a
neuromodulator having nerve blocks or
making lifestyle changes can also help
to manage migraine
symptoms for more information about
treatment for migraine talk to your
Healthcare
practitioner